happy hump day reject nation it's Greg
Alva here so for the first time in my
life just a couple days ago I watched a
record Ralph in hopes that they would
drop a trailer sometime soon my
foresight was correct and so they have
so we're gonna watch a trailer today for
wreck-it Ralph our to Ralph Rick's the
Internet if you want to know my opinion
on wreck-it Ralph you couldn't follow
that Stardust link in the description
box put up a little video for it over
there also one thing I wanted to mention
John Humphrey and I the real rejects are
gonna be versing the wild berries at a
Collider movie trivia Schmo down event
live people significant port Athiya tur
in North Hollywood
March 15th March 15th you can get your
tickets there's a link in the
description box for it there's a singles
match happening to JT e versus John Roca
it's gonna be a fun fun night I'm
looking forward to meeting as many of
you as possible I'm sure most of the
girls that show up will be there to meet
John Humphrey but I'll act like you're
there for me it's gonna be a good time
hit that link in the description box
several kinds of tickets you can get
looking forward seeing you folks
[Music]
all right let's get you plugged in yeah
whoopee or is it wifey line
[Music]
[Laughter]
No
[Music]
oh boy boy is that like a fun fun movie
man was that little girl Moana because I
heard she's gonna be in this movie
according to IMDB it looks like little
baby wanna in that moment actually which
I actually just saw for the first time a
month ago obviously I'm catching up on
my Disney films this looks like a great
follow-up to wreck-it Ralph it's gonna
be filled with a bunch of crazy
references this is gonna be insane man
because already exploring the arcade
world was nutty enough as it was and
there was so much to explore there that
Ralph's going through the internet will
just be incredibly nutty I really like
that it's established up front that him
and vanellope are gonna be sidekicks in
this specific adventure because I know
Penelope comes in a little bit later
into rekha Ralph's she's like the main
supporting character but she does come
in after act - it seems like she's gonna
be in this movie with him side by side
through him pretty much the whole film
which gets me excited because I love
that little girl animate a little girl
let me make that clear I love all the
weird internet references you have in
this video all the random stuff if do
you want to buy this do you want to see
this do you want to watch this video
just showing how incredibly absurd the
internet can be but you know one does
have to ask himself there's a very
specific type of website that is very
popular on the Internet arguably the
most popular thing people search for
online will Disney let Ralph find
certain hubs you got to think about that
for a second in some ways this movie
looks like a better version of the emoji
movie which I'm not sure how people are
gonna feel about that one person might
take it as this looks like how the emoji
movie should have been and some people
might go oh man this kind of reminds of
the emoji movie so it's probably gonna
suck a dad it's not gonna be a good film
because this looks like one crazy good
time to me you best believe that there's
gonna be a lot of internet companies who
are slapping their advertisements all
over this film I just love that ending
joke man with the bunny because he does
like he does that thing that in 7 where
you just feed a guy so much that he ends
up dying his body explodes
watching this video and then his buddy
just dies and it's just such an Internet
video thing to happen I know it's Ralph
interfering with the internet causing
that to happen but come on that is such
a random internet thing to do where
you're watching something lovely and
then something terrifying happens ah man
I'm really looking for it is the first
one I really enjoyed a lot I laughed a
lot I even cried a lot during that film
I'm hoping this one can be just as funny
and just as emotional just as
heartwarming at the same time because as
much as I love references and I love
absurdity you do got to have a main plot
that keeps it intriguing and engaging
and heartwarming all throughout all
right guys well are you excited for
wreck-it ralph to let me know what the
comment boxes Ralph breaks the internet
would be a better title to call it Ralph
Rex the Internet that's just my opinion
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up you can
check us out on patreon people
full-length TV show and music video
reactions over there TV show reactions
for attack on side and my hero academia
just started up Black Lightning the
flash Josue and Riverdale run away as a
full life music video is also weekly q
and A's would love to have you guys man
we're having a total blast doing it